bonjour et bienvenue dans fit l'écho
dans ce nouveau numéro nous allons voir
comment les yvelines se positionne dans
le monde des médias pme innovantes ou
encore lieu de tournage attractif
l'industrie audiovisuelle pèse lourd
dans le département notamment avec cette
pme installée à coignières aiguisé
motion créée en janvier 2011
benoît d'antan bonjour bonjour vous en
êtes le président nous sommes ici donc
dans vos locaux
expliquez nous ce que vous faites on
voit autour de nous des engins des
appareils et des motion est une société
spécialisée dans la prise de vue
aérienne est spécial donc nous avons
aujourd'hui plusieurs vecteurs qui
permet de l'utiliser donc ses moyens sur
les prises de vue en long métrage en
publicité aux événements de tous types
et surtout sportif
nous allons donc de très haut dans les
airs donc à partir d'hélicoptères
équipés des têtes gyrostabilisée qui
sont des plateformes stable sur lequel
nous mettons nos caméras
ensuite un peu plus bas nous avons des
plateformes sur câble donc des systèmes
qui s'appelle x fly'in chaix démotion
system x fly travail en multi dimension
où les voyez souvent dans les stades
comme au stade de france par exemple au
dessus des matchs de rugby
ensuite nous avons des systèmes donc de
véhicules travelling dont trois
principaux donc l'audi qui est une
un véhicule qui sert surtout pour les
tournages de formule 1 donc une voiture
très spécialisés pour la grande vitesse
le range rover qui était un véhicule
adapté pour des tournages présente dans
paris très compact il tourne
régulièrement le marathon de paris et
nous avons un troisième qui est en
tournage actuellement qui s'appelle le
rush une arme qui est assez
révolutionnaire qui est utilisée qui est
en fait une base de voiture avec un bras
robotisé qui sert énormément dans tout
ce qui est publicité long métrage et
événements avec cascades ensuite nous
avons des systèmes sur rail donc grande
vitesse qu'on utilise sur des tournages
d'athlétisme par exemple ou sur la
natation notamment sur les derniers
championnats d'europe de chartres où ça
a été utilisé et on est en train
d'évoluer maintenant sur la partie
drones donc les systèmes de
un volant est extrêmement miniature tout
ce qui est en images en mouvements du
sol jusqu'aux dents ciel vous est basée
dans les yvelines à coignières on le
disait est ce que pour vous c'est
stratégique au niveau de vos clients des
tournages alors c'est stratégique dans
le sens où en fait il ya énormément de
sociétés innovantes
il faut savoir que dans le berceau donc
des yvelines il ya eu beaucoup
d'entreprises militaires qui aujourd'hui
se sont un peu restructurer aussi pour
la partie civile
donc on utilise énormément de ce savoir
faire il ya énormément de laboratoire
d'étude de bureaux de conseils de bureau
d'études
donc ça c'est très important et j'ai une
fierté c'est justement d'essayer de
travailler uniquement avec des
entreprises locales
en tout cas en france mais si possible
dans un rayon d'action autour de mon
entreprise pour justement développer
localement avoir des facilités du
diffusion d'informations et de création
et franchement j'ai travaillé avant dans
le monde entier avec énormément
d'entreprises
on trouve tout ce qu'il faut dans les
yvelines donc stratégiquement c'est très
important de travailler avec ces
entreprises ici et vous fait aussi
partie d'un pôle de compétitivité du
département oui en fait on a été lauréat
donc les dernières sur le réseau
entreprendre yvelines donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'extrêmement
important parce que on fait des réunions
mensuelles où justement on participe
l'évolution de chacun nos entreprises
avec nos problèmes et nos solutions et
donc d'essayer de partager à ce niveau
là et aussi scientifique sur lequel nous
avons été lauréats qui nous a énormément
aidés
donc pour l'aspect financier du x fly
pour justement le générer le créer on a
l'impression que rien n'entrave votre
activité vous êtes récompensés vous
développez vos produits votre expertise
comment est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui on
sait on est en pleine crise économique
pour continuer à avancer
recruté le mélange de la facilité qu'on
a pu avoir dans les yvelines avec nos
partenaires locaux
avec ce consortium qu'on a créé et qui
s'appelle jim jones avec de plusieurs
sociétés qui sont spécialisés dans le
même domaine que le nôtre ça draine un
grand volant de clients et en
travaillant avec l'international
il faut s'ouvrir sur l'étranger ouvrir
sur les frontières essayer de travailler
en france avec des prix compétitifs bien
évidemment la concurrence est rude
il faut être présent avec des bons
tarifs mais on y arrive aussi parce
qu'en france on est capable de
construire à des bons prix des bons
tarifs pour qu'on ait une idée sur sur
un long métrage français par exemple
combien ce que vous louez vos services
de quoi est ce que ça dépend du matériel
utilisé voilà c'est à dire qu'en fait on
n'a pas la même valeur entre un tournage
hélicoptère qui va se situer dans une
fourchette de 7 8 mille euros la journée
pour quelques heures d'hélicoptère
jusqu'à un tournage qui va par exemple
lorsqu'on a tourné des événements
sportifs internationaux qui peuvent
aller à plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'euros pour cet événement bien
évidemment demandant beaucoup plus de
techniciens beaucoup plus de moyens
donc c'est des fourchettes qui sont je
dirais assez large en fonction du type
d'événement entre le long métrage la
publicité et le tournage mais on essaie
de se débarrasser de nous le plus vite
possible
en général la concurrence est rude en
france la concurrence est rude en france
elle est rude en europe
encore une fois on est dans un marché de
niche donc il ya plusieurs acteurs
européens
on n'est pas aidé en france par les
charges sociales pour les salariés c'est
quelque chose qui est relativement élevé
on a entre 20 et 30% et d'écart par
rapport au devis qu'on peut faire avec
nos concurrents étrangers
on est avec trois salariés permanents et
ont travaillé qu'un volant
d'intermittents du spectacle spécialisés
parmi les productions sur lesquels vous
avez travaillé ce que certaines étaient
situés dans les yvelines alors pas
encore on a fait moi dans ma carrière
j'ai travaillé beaucoup dans les
yvelines on a fait plusieurs longs
métrages puisque je suis aussi opérateur
de prise de vue aérien donc on a tourné
les choristes qui ont été tournées par
ici plusieurs longs métrages qui ont été
faits dans les yvelines on a aussi au
château de versailles j'avais cadrés
pour un très très beau plan suis un très
grand câble à l'époque on avait utilisé
sur le château de versailles donc oui il
ya des productions il ya des demandes
mais pas ses producteurs malheureusement
de films encore aujourd'hui par contre
c'est un lieu qui est assez prisé des
productions aux alentours parce que
voilà on a on a tout le côté historique
et tout le côté magnifique des parcs
naturels dans les yvelines pour les
tournages
merci beaucoup venaient d'entendre nous
avoir accueillis dans vos locaux des
grands plaisirs
nous écoutons à présent sylvie laguna du
comité départemental du tourisme des
yvelines qui nous en dit plus sur les
tournages à venir et puis les films en
2013 qui sortiront et qui ont été
tournées dans le département en 2013 on
va accueillir
on va avoir pouvoir voir les images d'un
nouveau film que l'on a accueilli
l'année dernière qui s'est tourné au
perray-en-yvelines c'est la grande
boucle avec clovis cornillac
elodie bouchez on se sert des films
comme outil de promotion pour le
développement touristique
mais c'est aussi un outil de
développement économique parce que
maintient un tournage ça rapporte à la
commune ça rapporte aussi il ya beaucoup
de films qui comme vous le savez se
tourne à versailles donc ça nous sert
d'outil de promotion à l'international
en disant voilà il existe des films qui
ont été tournés à versailles que vous
avez pu voir sa saison par le aux
clients et on leur dit il ya tout un tas
d'autres choses autour de versailles qui
peuvent être visités ou vous pouvez
venir et qui sont à découvrir donc nous
ça nous sert d'outil quand quant à
versailles mais également pour d'autres
lieux il ya eu coco chanel qui a été
tourné à houdan par exemple qui est une
petite ville médiévale et ça aussi ça
nous serve plutôt sur le marché français
l'autre c'est plutôt sur les marchés
internationaux
et puis on est là pour conseiller les
producteurs les régisseurs ceux qui
cherchent les lieux exacts parce qu'ils
ont des critères très particulier et
nous les demandent ils nous donnent des
critères et nous demande de trouver pour
eux le lieu adapté
alors c'est parfois une usine
désaffectée une école du style écoles
des années 50 enfin voilà donc faire des
recherches et on a une base de données
pour les pour les aider en la matière
nous sommes à présent à méré dans les
locaux de génériques
une entreprise qui propose des gammes de
produits low cost pour la coiffure je
suis avec bruno moche et bonjour bonjour
lui vous en êtes le fondateur de
collection venu vous voir en 2009 au
moment où vous installiez si vous aviez
à l'époque cinq salariés aujourd'hui il
y en a 18 ans on imagine que votre
activité se porte plutôt bien
oui par rapport à la conjoncture
effectivement on répond un phénomène de
société qui est le prix et je verrai
malheureusement plus la conjoncture est
dur et mieux on se porte
comment se passe exactement votre
activité à qui est ce que vous vous
adressez on a créé cette société en 2004
pour les professionnels donc on fait du
bit ou bi avant tout donc on s'adresse
qu'aux coiffeur corps professionnel donc
ceux des produits reconnus par des
professionnels diplômés et puis la gamme
et de qualité tout en étant le coche
parce qu'on réduit on peut avoir au tour
d'une autre entreprise qui est les frais
de force de vente technicienne et on
amène un produit de qualité à mon pays
alors votre activité est en train de
s'agrandir il en est de même votre
chiffre d'affaires le chiffre va avec
effectivement on a dépassé la barre des
5 millions
munoz et pour aller chercher les 6
millions pour 2013 vous attendiez à un
tel phénomène
un tel développement non pas du tout
c'est vrai qu'au départ c'était la
proximité avec des clients que j'avais
auparavant et puis c'est devenu un
succès donc mais on se rend pas trop
compte on bosse tous les jours et puis
ça se développe naturellement ce qui
nous intéresse particulièrement dans
cette émission c'est le côté audio
visuel de votre activité puisque vous
êtes partenaires de la star academy 1
cette émission donc diffusée sur une
chaîne de la tnt depuis quelques mois
quels sont les termes de ce partenariat
qu'est ce que ça apporte à génériques
alors là on recherche la notoriété on
est connu on est connu du be to be 1 des
professionnels mais pas du tout connu du
grand public
donc l'objectif de la télé on a commencé
en 2009 avec tf1 sur de la publicité sur
une nouvelle couleur qu'on avait sorti
et là c'est de montrer que l'on peut
être partenaire de mes missions
nationales
donc on est partenaire et coiffeur
officiel de cette émission qui nous
permet aujourd'hui d'avoir un bon buzz
sur facebook de servir du logo de
cervélo beaucoup de choses et de parler
de la marque au grand public non on
considère ça comme une publicité c'est
une cuve avant tout comme on vient de
faire une opération showroomprivé la
semaine dernière ont fait 95 min passage
sur notre site en une semaine
on gagne pas d'argent ils seront privés
où on fait connaître la marque sur la
star academy est ce que vous voyez déjà
les retombées sur votre activité
oui on a pris 1500 personnes
en l'espace de trois semaines sur la
page facebook l'activité elle est très
bonne donc c'est pas que grâce à sarah
kazemy c'est un ensemble de choses de
marketing direct d'expo qu'on fait on
fait 12 expo professionnels parents dans
quinze jours on est 1 en 3 semaines
après on va en belgique en forme on
bouge beaucoup
on se montre beaucoup vous utilisez le
dio visuel comme moyen de promotion mais
aussi le sport des événements c'est
votre stratégie de multiplier les
vitrines
oui tout à fait on a on n'a pas une
cible bien précise on était et est
partenaire du football en d1 sur
montigny-le-bretonneux il ya encore deux
ans
on sera à retenir de l'europride au mois
de juillet et 400 mille visiteurs
pendant dix jours à marseille donc c'est
une grosse manipulation avec une grosse
soirée privée générique on touche à tout
ce qui peut nous permettre de nous faire
connaître au niveau des produits ce
qu'il ya des projets des lancements à
venir on tombait bien parce que la
semaine prochaine on lance un vernis un
vernis pour cibler aussi le grand public
pourra mener cette marque générique dans
les salles de bains et puis le vernis
c'est un accessoire de mode c'est comme
le portable c'est si on n'a pas son
vernis dans son sac à main qui va avec
la chemise et pantalon
aujourd'hui on n'est pas branché et donc
c'est ce sont des produits qu'on pourra
trouver qui ne sont plus en bits ou bi
mes envies tout si vous les retrouverez
ensemble coiffure pour vous les sponsors
de coiffure vous les retrouvez sur le
site internet mais la priorité c'est de
développer le chiffre d'affaires et le
business des coiffeurs vous en prie
merci avant de se quitter on jette un
coup d'oeil à l'agenda le 29 janvier une
réunion d'information sur les métiers de
la poste vous est proposée à la cité des
métiers à trappes de 14h à 16h c'est
gratuit et puis le 8 février toujours à
la cité des métiers
un atelier sur les conséquence des
ruptures des conditions de travail pour
tout connaître sur vos droits
avec l'éclairage d'une juriste de 10h à
11h30
enfin jusqu'au 31 janvier l'exposition
tous en coopérative c'est à la maison de
l'environnement à magny les hameaux du
mardi au samedi de 14 heures à 18 heures
c'est terminé pour ce fils échos je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi c'était mon
dernier numéro je vous remercie aussi
pour votre fidélité
ok